hi everyone thanks for joining us for
our Western blot webinar today we'll be
going through the basic principles of
the Western blot and I'll show some
examples of troubleshooting this
technique remember that if you have any
questions please submit them to the Q&A
panel on the right hand side of your
screen and I'll be available to answer
some of them at the end of our
presentation so what is a Western blot
and how does it work it's a complicated
technique but to summarize it's used to
identify a specific protein of interest
within a sample containing many proteins
first the proteins are separated from
each other according to molecular weight
using gel electrophoresis and then a
specific antibody is used to identify
the protein of interest so we can
determine the molecular weight of the
protein of interest
by comparing the results to protein
standards of known molecular weight and
we can also determine the relative
quantity of the protein of interest
among samples for example in this
western blot image you can see that the
band of interest which is the control
protein beta actin is around 38 killa
Dalton's we compare to these proteins of
known molecular weight which are run
side by side with our samples in lane 2
less antibody was used to stay in this
particular sample and so the band
appears fainter than the others so
basically Western blots are useful tools
anytime you'd like information about
protein expression and your samples such
as those listed here they can be used to
indicate whether the sample expresses
the protein of interest at all or they
can be used to give information about
relative expression among different
samples or treatment groups they're also
useful to validate an antibody
specificity if your end goal is to use
it in immunohistochemistry or immuno
Saito chemistry as cross reaction can be
easily seen in Western blot since
proteins are separated from each other
visually in this presentation we'll go
over the steps of the Western blot and
talk about controls that should be used
during your experiment as well as the
selection of an appropriate antibody
for your assay I'll end with several
troubleshooting and optimization
examples of common problems in Western
blotting the first step to a Great
Western blot is preparing your sample
correctly because the final result will
never be a better quality than the
starting material there are three main
steps to preparing your sample lysis
measurement of protein concentration and
reduction and denaturation lysis
essentially soluble eise's the proteins
from the cells or tissue using buffers
and mechanical agitation all of this is
done on ice and with the addition of
fresh pretty ace inhibitors to the
buffer because keep in mind that there
are active protease enzymes in cells and
tissues that can break down your sample
if allowed the protocol is slightly
different for cells or tissue samples
but it's really the same concept
homogenized the sample and lysis buffer
and agitate then centrifuge and collect
the supernatant once the samples are
fully licensed entrer ssin you can use
the Bradford assay or BCA si whichever
method you prefer this will be important
to know for the electrophoresis step in
order to make sure you are loading equal
amounts of protein per sample the final
step of sample prep is reduction and
denaturation this breaks down
higher-level structure so that proteins
can be separated during electrophoresis
according to their primary amino acid
structure this is done by adding a
buffer containing a reducing agent as
well as detergent and heating generally
for five minutes around 95 degrees
heating at a lower temperature may be
more preferable for some proteins
particularly multipass membrane proteins
which in aggregate at higher
temperatures next we'll discuss lysis
reduction and denaturation a little
further so a few more suggestions for
the lysis step and this is important to
make sure proteins are actually fully
solubilized first as we discussed keep
everything cold and on
ice if possible and add protease
inhibitors fresh to the lysis buffer
additionally if you plan to detect a
phosphorylated form of a protein you'll
also need to add ample phosphatase
inhibitors finally the optimal lysis
buffer depends on the cellular
localization of the protein of interest
as a stronger buffer like mp40 or Ripa
is needed to fully soluble eyes membrane
or organelle bound proteins from the
cells for reducing and do naturing and
sample buffer the buffer contains two
agents SDS or sodium to deckle sulfate
and either beta mercaptoethanol or
dithiothreitol abbreviated dt t the SDS
is a denaturing agent with which helps
break the protein down to its amino acid
structure and it also coats the protein
and negative charges at a uniform rat
mass ratio this uniform ratio of
negative charges will be essential
during the next step of the procedure
gel electrophoresis beta mercaptoethanol
and dtt are reducing agents which break
disulfide bonds also breaking down the
protein to a linear primary amino acid
structure which is all simplified in
this image as a side note occasionally
the protein of interest will need to be
non reduced or nonde natured often
because a particular antibody only
recognizes this form of the protein and
so the reducing and denaturing steps can
be skipped if needed but most Western
blots are run and denatured reduced
conditions so once the samples are
properly prepared they're ready for gel
electrophoresis we've mentioned that gel
electrophoresis is used to separate
proteins
according to molecular weight we're
actually separating the proteins in an
electric field and taking advantage of
the fact that different sized proteins
will move through a gel matrix at
different rates
this image shows a typical apparatus
used for gel electrophoresis
the type of electrophoresis most
commonly used in Western blotting is
abbreviated SDS page SDS is the
denaturing agent which is added to the
buffer during this procedure page stands
for polyacrylamide gel electrophoresis
as the gels are typically made of
polymerized acrylamide so how does SDS
page work we start with a porous gel
matrix made of highly cross-linked
acrylamide submerged in a chamber filled
with an aqueous buffer samples of
protein lysates are loaded into wells of
the gel the well is the top of each lane
which is basically a depression in the
gel so there's space to hold the lysate
until the current is applied when the
current is applied the proteins will
migrate towards the positive pole as
they are coated and negatively charged
SDS because smaller proteins are less
inhibited by the gel matrix they will
move faster through the gel and when the
current is removed they will be farther
down the gel so proteins are separated
from each other according to size gels
are made of polymerized acrylamide and
cross-linked by best in the presence of
ammonium persulphate and timid and the
structure of the gel can be controlled
by altering the acrylamide percentage
basically by increasing the total
acrylamide percentage the pores of the
gel matrix become tighter which slows
down small proteins for this reason high
percentage gels are great when studying
smaller proteins and vice versa a lower
acrylamide percentage results in lower
in larger pores of the gel matrix which
allows larger proteins to migrate more
easily and separate more efficiently in
the gel there are also gradient gels
consisting of layers of different
acrylamide percentages so that both
small and large proteins can be
efficiently run on the same gels I would
recommend these if you're analyzing a
large range of range of proteins on the
same blot or
if you're unsure of the molecular weight
of your protein of interest as mentioned
previously sometimes you don't want the
protein of interest to be in the reduced
denatured form this will affect the
recipe of your running buffer during
electrophoresis as well as your loading
buffer during sample preparation here is
a chart that can be used as a reference
but basically you can remember that if
the protein needs to be and the nonde
natured also called native form remove
SDS from the loading buffer and the
running buffer if the protein needs to
be in the non reduced also called
oxidized form remove the beta
mercaptoethanol or DPT from the loading
buffer the next step after gel
electrophoresis is protein transfer the
transfer step is where the word blot in
Western blot originates because the
proteins are going to be transferred out
of the gel onto another surface this is
because gels are poor substrate for
immuno detection antibodies don't stick
to the proteins and the gels are very
fragile and can be easily torn so we
transfer the protein to a more durable
substrate for subsequent amino staining
so how does transfer work it's a similar
principle to electrophoresis and that
will move the negatively charged
proteins towards a positive pole in an
electric field the gel is placed
adjacent to a porous membrane and this
sandwich of membrane and gel is added to
a transfer cassette with the membrane
closest to the positive pole be careful
to avoid air bubbles between the gel and
membrane as air as an insulator and
won't conduct a current so proteins will
not transfer through the bubble I
suggest rolling the transfer sandwich
with the long edge of a conical tube to
remove air bubbles
once the sandwich is in the cassette an
electric field is applied in the
proteins migrate and adhere to the
membrane
in the same configuration as they are in
the gel there are many different kinds
of membranes available there are
different kinds of material commonly
PVDF or nitrocellulose and there are
also different pore sizes each have
different characteristics I suggest
using PVDF when blotting for proteins
that are difficult to transfer but PVDF
s can also contribute to high background
in some cases so you can try a few
different membranes and see what works
best with your system and with your
sample protein after transfer I always
recommend using a reversible protein
stain such as ponceau red on the
membrane to ensure that the proteins
fully transfer from the gel there are
two common methods of transfer wet and
semi dry the main difference being that
in wet transfer the sandwich is
submerged in the chamber filled with the
transfer buffer and in semi dry the
sandwich is placed directly between the
cathode and anode semi dry is faster but
the membrane can try out and inhibit
protein transfer what transfers more
time-consuming but it's the optimal
method to use when transferring a
protein that might be difficult to
transfer such as a large protein or
hydrophobic protein speaking of
transferring large proteins there are
some steps I recommend when transferring
proteins that are larger than 100 kilo
daltons use wet transfer and transfer
overnight at low voltage and low
temperature also add SDS to the transfer
buffer which will help prevent the
protein from precipitating in the gel
reduce methanol to 10 percent or less
and the transfer buffer which helps the
gel swell and release proteins if you're
using a PVDF membrane methanol can be
removed entirely from the buffer when
transferring large proteins it will also
be important again to use a Ponzo stain
on the membrane to make sure that the
protein
did indeed transfer after the protein is
transferred to the membrane it's ready
to be stained and visualized with a
specific antibody so why do we need
antibodies you could use a protein stain
like Kumasi and a gel or pond so on the
membrane but these are nonspecific
stains and we'll show every protein in
the sample such as the image on the left
it's very difficult to tell which
protein is the protein of interest and
it would be even harder to attempt to
compare the quantity of that protein
between samples so specific antibodies
are used so that only the protein of
interest is visualized as in the image
on the right the first step in the
immunostaining procedure is to block the
bare space on the membrane with the
neutral protein this is important
because the membrane is an adherent
surface for all proteins so free
antibody
could not specifically bind to the
exposed membrane but antibody shouldn't
bind to a neutral protein to block the
membrane the membrane will be placed in
a dish and covered with the solution of
key BST and three to five percent milk
or BSA the proteins in the milk or the
BSA bind to the membrane to cover the
free membrane so that antibody won't
stick to these areas later the dish
should be placed on a rocker to agitate
for an hour at room temperature or
overnight at 4 degrees Celsius once the
membrane is thoroughly blocked pour off
the blocking solution solution and add
the diluted primary antibody solution to
cover the membrane the antibody can be
diluted in TBS T or in the blocking
solution if you're using the antibody
for the first time with your sample you
may want to try a few different
solutions vanta body in order to find
the optimal dilution factor leave this
to incubate for an hour at room
temperature or overnight at 4 degrees C
on a rocker
and the antibody will bind to the
protein of interest on the membrane once
the antibody has bound the membrane
needs to be washed to remove any
residual antibody I would recommend
three to five washes with t vs t on a
rocker for around 10 minutes each wash
following the primary antibody the
membrane will be treated with the
secondary antibody that is conjugated to
a molecule that can be easily visualized
the secondary antibody will be specific
for the primary antibody so that it
binds to the primary antibody and thus
has extended Leibrandt bound to the
protein of interest leave the secondary
antibody to incubate for around an hour
at room temperature again wash the
membrane thoroughly to remove residual
secondary antibody three to five times
with t BST for around 10 minutes should
be sufficient once the membrane is
washed it is ready to detect the protein
via the Protea the molecule conjugated
to the secondary antibody there are
three kinds of detection that are most
commonly used with a Western blot the
first is detection using a
chemiluminescence substrate such as ECL
or ECL Plus which is more sensitive the
secondary antibody in this case would be
conjugated to HR P horseradish
peroxidase which catalyzes a reaction
with the ECL to produce a luminescent
signal which is captured on film
similarly a chroma genic substrate such
as for chloro naphthol or da b can be
used with an enzyme conjugated secondary
antibody to deposit a coloured product
directly on the membrane in this case
there is no special detection equipment
needed so it's a good choice if you're
just starting to run Western blots in
your lab a third option is to use the
secondary antibody conjugated to a
fluorescent molecule and the
fluorescence can be detected using
specialized detection system
as part of every well-planned experiment
there are certain controls that should
be used and now we'll talk about some of
the important controls to use in Western
blotting a loading control is often used
during Western blotting and it's an
antibody that is used in addition to the
antibody directed against the protein of
interest the loading control targets a
common protein that samplers should
contain in roughly the same proportion
so that assuming the same amount of
protein from each sample was loaded
correctly to the gel during
electrophoresis there should be
similarly sized band of the loading
controlled target if there was a mistake
during loading the loading control band
will show this error the target that you
choose will depend on what kind of
sample lysate you're using if you have a
whole cell lysate generally beta-actin
gap th or tubulin will be used as a
loading control for a mitochondrial
fraction use VDC a1 or Cox 4 and for a
nuclear fraction use a lamin b1 or
attach a binding protein antibody one
important note of caution is to be
careful when comparing loading control
results between dissimilar samples as an
antibodies binding affinity can vary
among different forms of the protein in
this image for example each Lane is
loaded with the same quantity of a
sample from a different species and
stained with a beta-actin antibody
although the lanes are loaded correctly
delay the band and the fish samples and
lane 3 is fainter than the others but
this is because the antibody has a lower
binding affinity for the fish beta-actin
protein in addition to a loading control
it's a good idea to run a positive
control and a negative control sample
alongside your unknown sample the
positive control is basically a sample
known to contain the protein of interest
such as a recombinant
protean a transfected cell line or
tissues or cells known to express the
protein a negative control is known to
not contain the protein of interest
which could be a knockout or si RNA
sample or tissues or cells that don't
express the protein of interest another
useful control is the blocking peptide
which is more commonly used with
antibodies in which the immunogen is a
short peptide sequence as opposed to a
full-length protein to use the peptide
as a control the antibody is pre treated
with the peptide so that the specific
binding sites of the antibody are bound
and blocked by the peptide then the pre
treated antibody is incubated with the
membrane any specific bands will not
appear on the membrane since the binding
sites are blocked if any strong bands do
appear they must be due to nonspecific
binding of the antibody in this image
there are no bands and lanes three and
four and this is because the antibody
used on these lanes was pre treated with
the immunogenic peptide in the other
lanes the antibody was pre treated with
peptides very similar to the immunogen
and since bands appear in these lanes it
demonstrates that the antibody is not
binding to the non immunogen peptides
showing the antibodies specificity next
we'll go over a couple of things to keep
in mind when selecting an antibody
appropriate for your Western blot the
first criteria which might seem obvious
is to choose an antibody that has been
tested successfully in Western blot this
is important because not all antibodies
will work well in Western blot if you're
on the ab cam website we will list WB in
the tested application section if we
have tested the antibody and it works in
Western blot so just make sure that that
to check that section when looking for a
suitable antibody
if Western blot is not listed as an
application the antibody was probably
not tested yet in this application we
encourage you to contact our scientific
support department in this case the
contact details for our scientific
support team will be given later in this
presentation
now the specific region of a protein
that an antibody targets may or may not
be important to your study if you're
studying a specific eisah form of the
protein or the precursor versus the
mature protein you should be interested
in the specificity of the antibody you
can often find out which region the
antibody targets by looking at the
immunogen sequence that the antibody was
raised against as the animal will
produced antibodies that recognize this
particular sequence if the antibody is
polyclonal then it will recognize the
entire immunogen sequence but if it is
monoclonal it will only recognize one
short part of the sequence if there is a
specific eisah form of a protein that
you are studying make sure the immunogen
region overlaps with the region that
your specific target contains so now
that we've covered how to run a Great
Western blot we'll talk about how to
troubleshoot the results when they
aren't as great as expected you might
eventually run a Western blot that looks
something like this image where the
lanes are completely blank or there
might be faint bands the expected
molecular weight if there are no bands
at all on the blot the protein might not
have transferred to the membrane which
can be checked again with a pond so
stain or maybe the secondary animal
antibody is not compatible with the
primary antibody it's possible that the
sample does not express the protein of
interest which can be checked using a
positive control sample side by side
with your unknown sample if the bands
are very weak you can increase the
amount of protein loaded and the
concentration of the antibodies used you
can change the blocking agent or block
for a shorter period of time and you can
increase the times of
antibody incubations if you're using a
chemiluminescent detection i would also
suggest exposing the film for a longer
period of time to pick up any bands that
might be on the block you could also run
into an issue of high background or more
bands on the blot than expected I would
recommend decreasing the amount of life
st. loading loaded onto the gel diluting
the antibody out further changing the
blocking agent and try again
nitrocellulose membrane if you're using
PVDF you can also decrease the exposure
time if you're using a chemiluminescent
detection if there are extra bands at
lower molecular weights in the protein
of interest degradation may be to blame
make sure protease inhibitors are added
fresh to the sample buffer and that the
samples are kept on ice if there are
extra bands and molecular weights that
are multiples of the expected molecular
weight such as that 100 killer Dalton's
when there should only be bands at 50
killer Dalton's foil samples a bit
longer to make sure any multimers are
disrupted you can check the literature
and I recommend the Swiss prout web
website to see if the protein is
modified post-translation such as with
glycosylation settle Asians or
phosphorylations
or if it has different isoforms or
cleavage fragments which could explain
the extra bands on the blot here is a
specific example from our own in-house
testing in which there was very high
background on a blot with a new lot of
an antibody the technician thought they
may have incorrectly diluted the
antibody which was intended to be at 1
microgram per mil so they simply remade
the working dilution from the stock
solution and they also diluted the
sample lysate 10 times and 100 times
just to be on the safe side and the new
result showed an ideal Western blot just
from diluting the antibody and sample
these are two other interesting cases as
these antibodies work much better with a
specific blocking agent the antibody on
the left as you can see shows multiple
bands when the membrane is blocked with
5% BSA however a clear yet faint band is
seen using 5% milk as a blocking agent
this isn't to say that milk is always
the ideal choice though the antibody in
the right image gives a much stronger
signal using 5% BSA and is barely
detectable in the membrane is blocked
with milk many antibodies will work just
fine with either milk or BSA but you can
experiment with different blocking
agents if the initial results are not
optimal if your blotting for a protein
using a phospho specific antibody
meaning that it should only detect the
protein if it's phosphorylated we
suggest using BSA as a blocking agent
milk endogenously contains phosphatases
which can cleave the phosphate group
from the protein of interest so that the
antibody cannot bind resulting in no
bands if we do know that a particular
antibody works better with one blocking
agent we will put that directly on the
datasheet but always feel free to
contact us about an antibody if you'd
like more details about how it's been
tested here is an example of a blot with
multiple problems and I'll just point
out that this antibody did not pass QC
and is not for sale so don't worry but
this image does show some common
problems that I'd like to discuss first
there is evidence of air bubbles that
were present during the transfer step
which did not conduct the current during
transfer and so protein did not migrate
to the membrane at this spot an easy way
to avoid this is to roll out the gel and
membrane sandwich using the side of a
conical tube tube while it's being
assembled there are also some spots of
poor washing where reagent has pooled on
the membrane to avoid this make sure all
solutions cover the entire membrane in
rock or agitate the membrane during
incubation
the last thing I'd like to point out is
the area and the right upper corner
where there was incomplete contact
between the gel and the membrane and
this may have been due to folding of the
gel or tearing of the gel if the gel
isn't flat on the membrane again smooth
out the sandwich with the side of a
conical tube to make sure all areas are
in contact if your gel is frequently
tear you can try using a different kind
of gel such as the optelec gels that
we've recently added to our catalogue
and these are up to ten times stronger
than traditional gels so there are lots
of things that can go wrong during a
Western blot but these are fixable
problems it's a good habit to stain your
membrane with upon so red stain after
transfer as you can catch these problems
early and rerun the electrophoresis and
transfer if necessary here's another
example of incomplete transfer but in
this case only the large proteins are
having trouble being transferred to the
membrane you can see that there should
be at least the high molecular weight
standard proteins but these have not
efficiently transferred if you see
something like this simply follow the
suggestions mentioned before for
transferring large proteins such as a
wet transfer overnight at low voltage
and lowering the amount of methanol and
your transfer buffer if you do see the
reverse problem meaning only high
molecular weight proteins are on the
membrane you may have over transferred
that the small proteins migrated
straight through your membrane so
shorten your transfer time or voltage in
that case finally for the last example
here's the case of an antibody that is
much higher affinity for the protein and
it's non reduced non denatured condition
meaning that SDS and beta
mercaptoethanol or dtt are not used in
the loading buffer or page running gel
this image was submitted as part of an
excellent AB review by an outside
researcher who found that a collagen 3
antibody gave a weak band when the
protein was reduced in denature
scene in the left lane and stronger
bands were seen when the protein was not
reduced into nature in the right lane
sample the band is around 300
kilonewtons is a dimer made of two alpha
chains that individually would run
around 130 kilonewtons and reduced
denatured conditions in its native form
the protein has a three-dimensional
shape and the antibody likely has a
strong binding site along the 3d shape
that is lost once the protein is reduced
and denatured on a final note I'd like
to reiterate how important it is to
really understand the biochemistry of
your protein of interest as Western
blotting depends heavily on this
knowledge each blog will not necessarily
give you one band at the expected
molecular weight but this isn't
necessarily a cause to worry there may
have been post translational
modifications or cleavage events which
caused the protein to run at a different
size or your sample may may express a
particular isoform of the protein when
on sure consult resources such as Swiss
prout website or the available
literature for more information about
your target and always feel free to
contact the Afghan scientific support
team if you need any assistance with
this with any part of your Western blot
contact details for the scientific
support team will be provided later in
the presentation now I'll turn the
presentation over to Mandeep who will
give an overview of the research tools
that ab kim provides for your western
blotting needs
Thank You Caitlin as I mentioned I am
going to review some of the product have
some offers to support your Western blot
experiment in addition to well
characterized primary and secondary
antibody to our catalog also includes a
number of products to support your
Western blotting the Maori agents range
to our mighty Sciences range to begin
with I am going to introduce our
reagents range which includes our core
Western blotting range Optive lot our
prism protein blooded as one of controls
and my face and ECL kick as Karen
mentioned a PDF of the slides will be
available for download after the webinar
there you can refer back to these links
our octave lock range includes gel
buffers and accessory reagents which are
designed to enhance your Western
blotting and improve on existing
products on the market using precast
gels from our optic block range you can
benefit from a 1 year shelf-life as well
as other features that make the gels
easier to use such as well that are easy
to visualize an increased strength and
ease of use to accompany the pre-cast
gel we also offer buffers that are
formulated for optimal running of the
gels which can be purchased or prepared
in the labs using butter recipes
available on our website
also our option block range includes
accessory reagents such as optic block
glue allowing you to stain proteins in
15 minutes an option block bradford
reagent will declare its compatible
protein quantitation we also offer
reagent bundles which and buffers you
will need to conveniently run your
experiments you can find additional
information about the optelec range by
visiting the link shown our reagents
range also includes pre-stained prism
protein ladders which can be used for
estimating the size of your protein and
determining Western blot transfer
efficiency with multicolored reference
by
so you can easily estimate the files of
operating and their broad range covers a
wide range of molecular weights
additional to Western blotting accessory
agents also include loading controls to
ensure equal amounts of life they are
loaded onto your gel life Apes which can
be used as positive controls and ECL
kits for sensitive detection please
visit the links shown to explore these
product ranges further if you work in
stem-cell research we have a range of
well tested antibodies for embryonic
stem cells such as octave or sox2 and
nanog for germ cell research we offer
for example DDX for dacl stellar GC NF +
CI w IL t for cancer studies these are
some of our best antibodies that we
would recommend for your research if you
are studying cancer metabolism we have M
tall tgf-beta and VG v ETS amongst
others for hypoxia we recommend our
hsp90 and here's one our proteins
antibodies you can find an evil even
wider selection of Western blot tested
antibody system cell cancer studies and
all other research areas by visiting our
website our canvas catalog includes over
2,500 secondary antibodies for Western
blotting secondary antibodies are mainly
coupled to enzymes such as HR P and
alkaline phosphatase we also have
antibodies that allow detection on
fluorescent scanners cross reactivity of
secondary antibodies with endogenous
immunoglobulins can be a concern
especially for when the sample tissue is
extremely rich in immunoglobulins to
solve this we have we recommend using
one of our pre absorb antibodies which
are available as pre absorbed against up
to three or eight species
with specificity of your secondary
antibody be an issue
we recommend using one of our FC
specific antibodies in contrast to
secondary antibodies recognizing the
heavy and light chain FC secondary
secondary antibodies only bind to the
heavy chain of the primary antibody for
example a goat and T Mouse IgG a channel
antibody could potentially bind the
light chains of other Mouse
immunoglobulins than itg this risk is
abolished
when using a goat anti-mouse ID g FC
secondary when using heavy and light
chain specific antibodies for Western
blot detection of amino precipitation
samples two bands can a pair appear the
heavy chain at around fifty kilo daltons
and the light chain at around twenty
five kilo daltons in the instances where
your protein of interest which has been
immunoprecipitated if in the 50 kilo
Dalton range the heavy chain can
obstruct the dissection of the band of
interest to solve this problem simply
use one of our light chain specific
secondary antibodies which will no
longer recognize the heavy chain just to
remind you you can find out additional
information about the products mentioned
in this overview on the link shown on
the slides as well as in a PDF copy of
the webinar which will be available for
download at the end for more hints and
tips you can find information about
Western blotting protocols guides and
frequently asked questions and also our
optical range on our upcam website using
the links shown the outcome scientific
support team will be happy to help you
with any queries you may have support is
available in a number of languages
including English Chinese Japanese
Spanish German and French
in northern South America you can
contact us at our us office for Hong
Kong China and Asia you can contact our
Hong Kong office for UK and Europe you
can contact our UK office and for Japan
our Japan office thank you for your time
I am now going to pass you back to
Caitlyn
who would answer some questions which
have been received okay great thanks to
everyone who sent in questions we'll go
over as many as possible time permitting
it looks like a lot of people have
questions about using loading controls
about the same protein about the same
size as a protein of interest so there
there are a couple of different options
that you have when using loading
controls so beta-actin is one of the
more commonly used loading controls and
that's about 38 killa Dalton's but if
your protein of interest is around 38
killa Dalton's and you still want to use
beta-actin you can probe with your
beta-actin antibody and then strip that
antibody from the membrane and then and
then use your other antibody you can
certainly do that we do have a protocol
for stripping and reproving on our
website on the ab cam website and the
scientific support section there there
is a protocol for doing that I would
recommend just using a loading control
that it's a that is that a different
molecular weight there are several
different options for loading controls
for any kind of protein or any kind of
sample that you have so it would
probably be easier to just use a
different loaning control and the
benefit of doing that if you have a
loading control that's a significantly
different molecular weight and your
protein of interest you can actually
after transfer you can
cut the membrane and then stain using
those two different antibodies
completely separate from each other that
way you won't have to go through the
extra step of stripping the membrane and
rhe probing and every time you strip you
can lose some of the protein off of the
membrane which can affect your results
if you're if you're trying to to
quantitate or just qualify the amount of
your protein of interest between samples
so I would recommend choosing a
different loading control than one
that's close to your protein of interest
there's a question about gradient gels
from asada Thank You asada do you have a
specific protocol for preparation of
gradient gels or are they available
commercially I would recommend just
purchasing them you you can make them
but it will be much easier to just
purchase them and they're available in a
in different ranges of acrylamide
percentage a common one is just four to
twenty percent or four to twenty percent
and with that range you can you can
analyze a very large number of sized
protein so I would recommend just
purchasing a four to 20 percent gradient
gel we have a question from dev about
how long do primary antibodies typically
last
I used a five-year-old antibody and
didn't see any signal and could the
antibody have degraded the answer is yes
five years an antibody will probably be
viable stored at minus twenty degrees
Celsius but they can certainly degrade
upon storage so I would recommend if the
antibody was working fine prior to
storage just go ahead and get a new
antibody it probably has been damaged
upon storage we have a question from
Luke about asking for some more advice
for phosphorylated proteins to repeat
again what to use for phosphorylated
protein so the first step is make sure
you include phosphatase inhibitors
during your sample preparation as well
as protease inhibitors if you aren't
already doing that on a regular basis
and the the second step that we
mentioned was to to use BSA you can use
three to five percent BSA as your
blocking buffer instead of the milk so
the milk has enzymes in it naturally
that can break down that phospho protein
and then your antibody won't be able to
bind to it and we had a question from
Balaji asking if blocking peptides are
available for phospho antibodies and yes
they are generally for most Faso
specific antibodies there is a peptide
available if it's a an antibody that
detects one specific phosphorylated
residue on the protein the immunogen
would have had to be the that specific
region so a peptide either can you can
make a peptide if there's not one
commercially available but you would
know that you would have to make a
peptide to that region and
phosphorylated at that specific residue
so there is a question from musu I
sometimes have spots around my bands
when I develop my membrane I've
increased washing periods and based on
the pond so there were no air bubbles
[Music]
I'm assuming spots might may be kind of
a speckled a speckled appearance just
across the membrane and and sometimes
you see that if the blocking solution
the BSA or the the milk powder isn't
fully dissolved in in the solution in
the PBS t and so you end up with with
some speckles or some dots on your
membrane there could also be some
contamination in in one of your
solutions and and that can show up as as
dots or speckles so if you think it
might be contamination of course you can
either sterile filter your solutions or
you can create you can make new
solutions if you think
you're having some trouble fully
dissolving your your milk or your BSA
powder in that tbfp you can also filter
your blocking solution after you add the
powder and that can get rid of any any
speckles that might be forming that have
its it's not an issue with the transfer
so your pond so stain will look okay but
they're just showing up because of the
presence of other things in your
solutions we have question for a minute
I don't have a homogenizer but I have a
sonicator can this be used to lice my
tissue and you you can use the sonicator
that's perfectly fine something to keep
in mind with the sonicator is the
solution can get very warm and and so
you'll need to make sure that you're not
sonic a ting for long periods at a time
sonic ate for maybe fifteen to thirty
second intervals and then cool your
solution in between the sonication
periods and just make sure your so your
sample is still on ice even while your
Sonic a ting so she's very important to
make sure your sample doesn't get hot
and that heat can damage your protein
and and then you might end up with high
background on your blot as well we have
a question from Kent
I keep seeing secondary antibodies that
are called pre adsorbed what does that
mean and and do I need to use them for a
Western blot the pre absorption is
basically an extra pretreatment that is
done to some secondary antibodies and it
removes any molecules that might be
cross reacting with other species than
the intended species so if you have an
anti Mouse secondary antibody that's
been pre adsorbed and means it's been
pre treated to remove any anti rat
molecules or any
rabbit molecules so that the secondary
is specifically anti-mouse you don't
have to use this for your Western blot I
think would be more important for
Western blot following an amino
precipitation but it you should be fine
to use a non pre absorbed secondary
antibody on your Western blot and we
have a question from Ling someone in my
lab ran a Western blot and the blot was
black but the bans are for white can we
fix this and the answer is yes white
bands on a black blot it's it's called
inverse banding and it's normally caused
by using too much antibody if you're
using chemiluminescence for detection so
the film is kind of quenched and
overexposed and you should be able to
fix this by just diluting the primary
and the secondary antibody further and
so the blot looks normal and and you see
black bands on a white background again